[Music]
welcome to the 80s greatest hits
now we're entering a strange world of
make-believe
cuteness and charm and some creatures
that quite frankly i find terrifying
we're talking about the top 10 toys
[Music]
all the best toys came out in the 80s
they were way more than child's play
they were hot toys created during a cold
war
it was a torture device thinly disguised
as a children's toy
when old barriers began to break down my
little pony is the flyest thing ever and
toys
first found their voice
capturing the minds i have the power you
imagine if you could do that in real
life
and hearts i'm sorry i need to hook up
of a new generation but what was the toy
that conquered them all
now we're gonna find out
[Applause]
without further ado
here would be our unnerving
number 10.
[Music]
the 80s where individual dreamers
harness technology to their imagination
creating toys that would inspire
millions and make untold millions for
their inspired creators
hi my name is teddy ruxpin hi there how
are you i'm teddy ruxpin can you and i
be friends
you know this was like the good version
of chucky you know that spoke to you and
it wasn't going to kill you say hello to
our new friend it's kind of a
frightening looking bear can you and i
be friends you're really going to give
this to a child
well actually yes 1.7 million of them in
two years to be precise it was just an
amazing thing and created a phenomenon
and people had never seen anything like
it and we forget that today
teddy ruxpin is the brain child of a
dreamer named ken forsey an american
designer of robotic disneyland
attractions
ken had been developing the bear since
the late 60s but it was not until the
decade's advances in technology when his
dream took furry form
the technology was by today's standards
fairly simple
he had a cassette player in the back and
one track of the cassette player was the
story told by teddy
plus some songs and the other track was
a code track that would make teddy's
mouth move and his eyes blink
kids today are totally spoiled all their
toys talk to them they do whatever they
want but there was no toy like that
before it was just pure magic
you know
i can't sleep either
the babbling bear launches in time for
christmas 1985.
teddy is an instant hit despite his
hefty price tag
oh my goodness
jaws drop when people first meet teddy
ruxpin the mechanical bear who runs on a
microchip that runs a tiny motor all of
which runs for about 70 bucks
it was just an outrageous price point uh
i shouldn't really say that
my mom bought one
which was spellbinding clearly we could
afford the finest things in life
teddy ruxpin may be an expensive luxury
but parents didn't care they're
desperate to get their hands on him
i think maybe in some ways teddy was a
surrogate for parents who were
very busy
in the early 80s more parents than ever
are working outside the home which means
moms and dads have less free time to
entertain their kids
[Music]
enter teddy ruxpin friend and virtual
nanny i can't sleep either but i've
learned a little trick to help me i sing
myself to sleep
actually every story that we told had
some sort of moral
i really enjoy talking to people and so
i think parents were very very
comfortable with uh what we were
projecting
i like it because it would keep me
company
i was obsessed
love teddy ruxpin
but poor teddy ruxpin is soon destined
to meet his maker sales plummet when
knockoff copies and cheaper rival
products flood the market
everyone tried to be the next teddy
ruxpin this is a bear that listens to my
voice and then talks back in bear talk
manufacturer worlds of wonder failed to
come up with another hit
and in 1988 just three years after
teddy's release
they go bust
give you an iv friends yeah i think
we've been friends for a very very long
time teddy since 1985 1985
are you kidding well how old must you be
let's not talk about that right now
[Music]
our number nine revolves around a woman
who had dreams as a little girl of
owning a pet
she never forgot them and when she grew
up she realized that millions of other
little girls might have had the same
dream as well
and she was right
[Music]
i was obsessed with my little pony i
begged my mom for every single color
all of that beautiful hair you could
make it fluffy and curly or keep it nice
and tight and perfect
my little pony is one of the decades
most popular toys
but who knew its unbridled success would
owe so much to ronald reagan's
deregulation of tv
my little pony was part of this whole
movement that happened in the early 80s
reagan unleashed toy companies to
advertise directly to kids and to also
make cartoons starring the same toys
they want to sell
now it's open season
uh-oh yeah it was there to entertain the
kids but it was also there as a
springboard to them buying more stuff
[Music]
and toy makers decide the best way to
stand out in a crowded marketplace is to
double down on gender-specific toys
now all hasbro needs to do is come up
with the next big thing for girls
there's a dreamer in the house of hasbro
her name is bonnie zackerly
the one thing in the world i always
wanted was a horse
my father always promised me someday
when we retire and we get the dream
house in the country you'll have your
own horse wish i wish
i wish i never got one never did sad to
say
but i knew there were girls like myself
who would like horses and if i could
make them into a small soft little doll
it would be a good toy
bonnie is adamant her little horse
should have a true to life appearance
hasbro disagrees
i wanted natural colors i was a horse
woman i wanted palomino dapple gray but
the rest as they say is history
hasbro wants there to be no mistake this
is a girl's toy so before bonnie's horse
is ready for market hasbro demands a
glamorous makeover
if you ask anyone in the toy industry
the magic combination for little girls
it's glitter bright colors and hair play
this type of rigid gender stereotyping
might not fly today but in the 80s it
was just business as usual
in the 80s everything for girls got
really pink and really purple
and my little pony just encapsulated
that whole princess thing inside of a
pony
after the ponies land in toy stores a
cartoon follows introducing kids to an
entire range of new characters they can
take home
the sensation of like having your own
little pony and grooming it and braiding
its hair i don't know it kind of made me
feel like i had a pet
by the end of the decade over 150
million my little ponies are lovingly
stabled in young girls bedrooms all over
the world
and even today the miniature horses
refuse to be put out to
show me some magic
i can do this
[Music]
my little pony captured the hearts of a
generation of girls and guess what some
boys liked them too
my little pony is the flyest thing ever
they were beautiful i wanted one
that thing was gangster
two down eight to go
it's been said that art imitates life
but in the 80s art imitated larger than
life
as muscle men raged across our movie
screens our number eight toy was doing
exactly the same thing only this guy was
doing it in plastic
[Music]
luke skywalker was just a farm boy until
he received a mysterious message from a
princess
help me obi-wan kenobi
she's beautiful
in 1976
toy company mattel turned down the
chance to make action figures for a new
film destined for obscurity
i find your lack of faith disturbing
they've been licking their wounds ever
since
so mattel needed a reaction really quick
they needed a line of their own without
purchasing the rights to a film
franchise like star wars
the action figure market is very much
targeted at boys and drawing their
attention away from star wars is no easy
task
but if the start of the decade taught
mattel one thing
fantasy plus muscles equals millions
what is best in life
to crush your enemies
see them driven before you and they hear
the lamentation of the women
to measure up to the decades new
masculine ideal mattel is convinced
their new toy has to be one boys can
admire and it can only help if he has a
catchy well catchphrase
i have the power
at the start of the 80s muscle cell and
size matters toy maker mattel
want to take this notion of hyper
masculinity and transform it into an
action figure for boys and mattel had
just the dreamer for the job and that
man had a he-man of his sleeve
so i've been developing very heroic
figures from the time i was a little boy
and he-man was openly proud of his body
like arnold schwarzenegger i mean these
guys aren't shy about it and i wanted
this guy to be powerful with no
questions asked
and i don't mean a superman and god-like
power i mean a hero
he was this massive guy
the thing that always amuses me is that
all his opposing muscle groups are
flexed at the same time which is
impossible physiologically
the masters of the universe toy line
with he-man leading the charge is
released in 1982 and to further boost
sales mattel takes the lesson of star
wars and applies it in reverse
unlike the star wars figures which seem
to be an afterthought to the movie
masters universe was engineered as a toy
first cartoons came later
and the masters of the universe the
he-man animated series first airs in
1983.
soon boys all across america have a new
favorite macho role model that gives
prepubescent lads something they yearn
for revealed to me the day i held aloft
my magic sword one day i held them off
the magic sword exclaimed by the power
of grayskull
[Applause]
i have the power
when you're a child you have no power
whatsoever everybody is taller than you
everybody's in charge of you but you
know at play you could have the power
and with that power there is no better
villain to fight than he-man's notorious
nemesis
so he-man it's just you and me
skeletor stands for everything that was
not he-man he's depressing he's sneaky
he's a liar
very clever you muscle-bound [ __ ]
the thing about he-man that really
resonated with kids was he started as
prince adam sort of a normal person
by
but he transformed into he-man
he-man showed boys that you can be kind
of a regular kind of guy but when needed
you could be strong and brave and a hero
and i think kids really felt that
at its peak nine million kids tune in to
watch he-man every day and by 1986 the
action figures rack up 400 million
dollars in sales
just like my little pony he-man's legacy
lives on with a new series set to
entertain fans young and old
i have the power
mr plastic thought he had the power but
there was no escaping cuddly characters
in the 80s and our number seven was
biologically engineered to take no
prisoners in that area
[Music]
at the start of the decade childhood is
changing
it was a time when we began to really
validate children's emotions as part of
their developmental process
unlike their own repressed parents 80s
moms and dads want their kids to voice
their feelings
and it's very reinforcing to kids
because kids don't always feel happy and
joyful
toy industry legend bernie loomis dreams
big
and senses the time is right for a new
generation of teddy bear
one that is ready made to meet the needs
of this new generation of children
we started with a blank piece of paper
we said bears have always been popular
and then somebody said how about doing
tummy graphics on bears let's have them
represent
emotions
[Music]
i
loved
care bears
to me the care bears were everything
my personal favorite was sunshine
and tender heart
and grumpy i know that's more than one
favorite
loomis is so confident the bears will be
a success he spends two years and
millions of dollars producing an entire
product range
and he releases it all at once
there's a friend bear a cheer bear a
grumpy bear one mother says that every
morning her kids sit down next to her
and tell her what kind of bear they're
going to be that day
loomis's care bear blitz is a gamble but
it soon pays off
kia bez are not only number one in the
states the number one in england number
one on the continent and
it's really an interesting worldwide
phenomenon
i knew we would if i wished hard enough
they had their emotion like on their
little stomach can you imagine if you
could do that in real life if you're
having a bad day hey just don't mess
with me man look at the rain cloud
brilliant
brilliant
in five years 40 million care bears
march off the shelves generating over a
billion dollars in sales and it goes
without saying the bears that care star
in their own movie
[Music]
will all their love and caring stop a
shadowy spirit from stealing away every
feeling in the world
i think the reason care bears appeal to
girls so much is because they could
defeat evil just by caring and by being
friends
the care bears conquered the 80s and not
only that they lived to tell the tale
after all these years their mission to
spread sharing and caring is still going
strong
even today we stock care bears in the
store and care bears are currently sold
out
it's still a really hot property
care bears are sitting cute and pretty
at number seven but with six more to go
our play time is far from over
next up it's a fact-filled phenomenon
that 40 years ago no dinner party could
be complete without the people who'd
ruined it for everybody else were the
loudmouths
all right trivia time
what 1983 movie featured the debut of
the 80s hottest actor
[Music]
the outsiders wait a minute that wasn't
matt dillon's first movie
they're talking about me
next question why was this only number
six
[Music]
at a time when we are inundated with the
important a threat of nuclear war a fact
of unemployment the trivial can be a
relief
[Music]
in the early 80s you had to have a
trivial pursuit game
[Music]
it was a huge game huge
everybody was playing it
you don't want to play me in terminal
pursuit trust me
i have never lost
what was it that inspired you to design
a new game are you bored with everything
on the market or
it was about a case of beer quesadilla
on december 15 1979 journalist pals
chris haney and scott abbott settle in
for a quiet game of scrabble only they
can't play when they discover some
letters are missing and the two men have
the same dream at the same moment
and uh chris said why don't we invent a
game what could it be about
and i said trivia we sat down and did a
little doodling and half an hour later
it was all done
this is it no electronic joysticks no
hungry pac-men just an old-fashioned
board game with 6 000 questions all of
them trivial ranging from sports to
science
timing as they say is everything and
when trivial pursuit is released in 1982
it is the right game at just the right
moment
it was the time of the 24 hour news
cycle you had the rise of cnn in the
1980s so people were being inundated
with all kinds of knowledge and
information and trivial pursuit played
into that
sure they have all the popular games
here like boggle and pente and scrabble
over here but the one they can't keep on
the shelves is one that cost forty
dollars it's called trivial pursuit
that was a lot of money we certainly
were coming out of a recession at that
time
but it was actually a fairly affordable
way to have an evening
you know the 80s was so much about being
bright and bold and over the top you
know look how smart i am look at how
much useless information i know what's
the name of the piece flipped into the
cup in tiddlywinks
oh gif
it came along before the internet before
google this game really depended on you
having the trivia in your brain box it
was a game that attracted really
insufferable people
i had a manager by the name of bob ellis
who used to be married to diana ross and
we went to bob ellis's house every
saturday night for five years to play
trivial pursuit i won every time
by the end of 1984 trivial pursuit
generates almost 800 million dollars and
turns its makers into multi-millionaires
but this success is no trivial matter
and the author of a trivia encyclopedia
fred wirth believes he has been ripped
off
about 32 percent of the material that is
in their genus edition the original
edition
could be found in my book
in a move worthy of lieutenant frank
columbo himself worth plants a fake fact
in his trivia book giving that fictional
detective the wrong first name
phillip and when that wrong name appears
in the game fred not frank pounces it's
a falsehood doesn't exist and you won't
find it anywhere except in my book and
it's one of their questions
worth sues for 300 million dollars but
the judge throws out the case ruling
that trivia can't be copyrighted even if
it is wrong
trivial pursuit goes on to become the
decade's hottest property even
outselling monopoly which has dominated
the adult games market since the 1930s
it jumped that rubicon from sort of cool
game to cultural phenomenon
but in the age of the internet with
relentless amounts of useless
information only a click away
trivial pursuits popularity declines
perhaps some games are just a product of
their time
it was just another way to be loud and
domineering which was kind of an 80s
quality
all right five toys down five toys to go
and the competition is gonna get vicious
now our number five toy is far from
trivial and has led to some of the
biggest
and loudest movies ever made
in the high-tech 80s japan's electronics
lead the way
there was a real consumer technology
revolution coming from the pacific rim
and american consumers were huge
beneficiaries
and at the tokyo toy fair of 1983 hasbro
spots a toy that will revolutionize
action figures here come the bots
the toy company hasbro is calling the
transformer the biggest thing from japan
since godzilla transformers started in
japan as transforming robots
they became trucks they became cars they
became planes
and that's really all they did
hasbro loved the concept but fear kids
won't know why they should want them to
guarantee transformers reach their
target audience the toy maker comes up
with an intergalactic solution
in 1983 hasbro spots the potential for
revolutionary new japanese toy
but to be a hit this side of the pacific
the transforming robots need an identity
that an 80s generation of jaded kids can
connect with
thing that makes american toys really
good is that a little bit of edge of
drama
when it comes to the action figure
you've got to establish story and
characters and it does take a show to do
that
hasbro turns to marvel and marvel comes
up with the idea of opposing forces of
good and evil robots locked in an
endless civil war
in 1984 the toys and animated series are
released at the
[Music]
you see this cartoon and you see optimus
prime transformed from this robotic
alien into a truck and back again you
buy the toy it does it it actually does
it decepticons attacking autobots
transform and meet me there
there was something about optimus
prime's voice
very perceptive
that i was just instantly drawn to it
off the back of the cartoon toy sales
surprise surprise go through the roof
helped in no small part by a stellar
cast of characters
kids just love the show i love doing it
why did you tell us they were
decepticons if you had we would have
been interested earlier instead of
disruptive september consecrance the
subject cuts above me decepticons below
me every place i look i see decepticons
i don't have to unbend
i've had people come up to me and say
you know what was it like in episode 54
when your struts melted i'm like well
you know i'm a human being and i don't
have struts and i don't know what my
strengths felt like when they melted and
the autobots eternal battle with the
decepticons shows no sign of ending with
modern reboots still coming fast and
occasionally furious my name is optimus
prime
we are autonomous robotic organisms from
the planet cybertron
transformers really is one of those
lines that's captured imaginations for
multiple generations now
[Music]
transformers were two toys for the price
of one i mean to make that actually work
in a plastic toy still blows my mind
[Music]
motorized vehicles that transform into
law of physics defying robots got it
and as for our number four toy of the
1980s well their creators heard that
insane transformer mythology and said
hold my beer
[Music]
teenage mutant ninja turtles is so funny
to me because it started out as a joke
turtles that have been exposed to
radioactive ooze and turned into
surf talking characters who liked pizza
and had names of renaissance painters
a phenomenon like turtles you cannot
plan for
the story of the turtle's bumpy rise to
toy supremacy begins in new hampshire
1984.
down on their luck cartoonists kevin
eastman and peter laird are just fooling
around when they accidentally dream up
an empire
kevin drew a turtle standing upright
with a mask on and wearing nuchakus on
his forearms
it was an effort to make pete laugh i
dubbed it a ninja turtle and we got into
dueling sketches
they named the four sewer dwelling
superheroes after 15th century painters
and get busy writing them their own
comic strip
they were designed to satirize this sort
of traditional action hero
the self-published comics surprise
success lands the cartoonist a deal with
toy manufacturer playmates he-man
designer mark taylor is hired to turn
the 2d turtles into 3d action figures
and these two guys they are so poor
their shoes
were held together with duct tape and
they said what do you think of it i said
it's good these guys are a group that
care about each other and they're like
the musketeers one for all and all for
one
mark works his modeling magic but toy
shops aren't prepared to shell out for
radioactive reptiles
it was a disaster
everybody looked at turtles and said
these can't be heroes this will never
work
but by now the 80s has a tried and
tested formula to get kids into toy
stores
and the decision was made that the only
way this would work as a toy product was
to create an animated show
based on the original comic books
[Music]
[Applause]
everything about the ninja turtles was
kind of cool right they were party dudes
they were like teenagers they lived in
the sewer
all the ada's pizza when you're a kid
all you want to do is eat nothing but
pizza the turtles did that
and kids can't seem to get enough of the
rebellious teenage turtle toys for
obvious reasons they offer something
they've not seen before
let's not forget that the 80s really
started with straight laced
fantasy-filled characters such as a
he-man or thundercats everything was
played pretty straight teenage mutant
ninja turtles was brilliant in the 80s
because it started to change the
perception of what a superhero really
means and who could be a superhero
turtles was one of the first ones to
really mix in a healthy dose of humor
and it was that humor that ended up
being
one of the differentiating elements we
turtles don't know the meaning of the
word defeat that's right we never
bothered to look it up in the dictionary
don't you guys take anything seriously
after the show had aired a few times i
walked in to a toys r us store
completely empty shelves and at that
point i knew we finally had something
good on our hands
turtle mania quickly takes hold selling
1.1 billion dollars worth of toys in
just four years and then inevitably the
boys in green get their own movie
cementing their status as one of the
decade's biggest brands
i love being a turtle
surfing teen turtles crest a wave onto
our scoreboard at number four but coming
up in our top 10 toys the underground
game so out there it almost got banned
we are now entering the rarefied
atmosphere of our top three toys of the
80s
our next contender began with a man
whose world turned inside out when he
lost his job so he created a new world
one inside the human mind
no batteries or assembly required
[Music]
my entire knowledge of dungeons and
dragons in the 80s would based entirely
on the movie e.t because the kids in e.t
play dungeons and dragons
i'm ready to play now you guys we're in
the middle early can't you join any
universe in the middle
it was always the smart kid who played
it so
that's probably why i didn't
i've seen films about people that play
dungeon dragons and they're serial
killers
[Music]
in the late 70s gary gygax loses his job
in insurance so gary fills the hours yes
you guessed it dreaming up fantasy war
games and of course his basement
little did he imagine the game he dreams
up will become one of the decades most
controversial dungeons and dragons it's
basically a role-playing fantasy game
you've got the players who are creating
their characters
you have a dungeon master who is setting
up the story
you also had weird shaped dice and 40
years ago the game gets popular amongst
the unpopular kids
dungeons and dragons was nerd heaven
if you felt like your own life sucked if
you were getting picked on if you felt
like you were a puny little kid you
could be some like kick-ass elf with a
bow and arrow right and you felt
empowered it would feel much better if
if we knew that we were a
superhero or a mighty wizard of the
stamp of conan or merlin or whoever
being a nerd started to become
kind of a cool thing in the 80s a little
bit
and i think dungeons and dragons was was
definitely part of that
soon d d clubs spring up in schools all
across america
but by the mid-80s as the game's legend
spreads parents start to panic
why this time
this morning we're going to take up the
controversy surrounding the game
dungeons and dragons which some parents
fear could lead to violence and suicide
there was a big scare about satanism
about sorcery and dungeons and dragons
you know seemed like it was part of this
dark netherworld there was a movie that
came out in 80s with tom hanks that was
about like a dungeons and dragons
inspired moral panic people were scared
of this stuff
i impart you a holy man
in reaching the ninth level i have
acquired many magic spells and charms
the greatest of which is the graven eye
of timmer
anything in the 80s that seemed like it
was slightly dabbling in magic was
really terrifying
to especially you know people in the
bible belt to some parents
despite concerns there is no evidence
the game is involved in any teen deaths
if anything the bad press encourages
more kids to buy the game by 1986 it
attracts around 4 million fanatical
followers
dungeons and dragons captured the
imagination of a generation and when
those kids grow up they're destined to
dream of even bigger fantasy worlds the
creators of game of thrones i know play
d even today so it helped i think
inspire a lot of creative people
i know that it inspired stranger things
a shadow girls on the wall behind you
swallowing darkness
it is almost here what is it
a lot of the monsters and things in the
show are taken directly from dungeons
and dragons
the demogorgon
and just be careful who you call a nerd
dungeons and dragons typically has been
associated with your nerd
and now all these years later those
geeks and nerds have have grown up to
rule the world
in the 80s not only did people want
their mtv their vhs machines and their
leg warmers
some parents just had to have something
else
and that trend
got a little out of hand
are number two
in memphis tennessee pushing
shoving
scratching
one store official armed himself with a
baseball bat
wiltsbury pennsylvania it was a near
riot one woman broke her leg four others
were hurt
this is what the fuss is all about pudgy
faced little dolls called cabbage patch
kids
the cabbage patch kids are the decade's
ultimate toy craze that no one saw
coming
except perhaps for their creator dreamer
xavier roberts when we started the
company we really had big dreams most of
the people the bankers thought we were
crazy and they thought a bunch of kids
couldn't
do something like this robert started
making and selling the doll six years
ago they proved so popular he decided to
go into business full
time roberts then licenses his creation
to toy manufacturer cooliko
in 1983 mass production begins and a
computer-operated manufacturing process
makes certain no two are the same
it was a different doll for everybody
that's why it was so special and i like
the little brown ones oh cause i was
brown and i was like okay
look a little brown face like mine
the idea behind the dolls was that you
were adopting them and they came with a
birth certificate
it was like your own little kid i guess
and it tapped into that nurturing sort
of thing that all of us have
[Music]
in february 1983 the mass market version
of the doll launches and demand slowly
begins to grow
driven by an unstoppable force
commercial mayhem will soon ensue
[Music]
in 1983 the cabbage patch kids take over
america every christmas had a hot toy
this was the toy that year why because
an army of hungry consumers feel like
they have to own one
remember that reagan revolution about tv
deregulation there was a commercial for
the cabbage patch doll each doll is
different and you can pretend to adopt
them my baby has a real diaper that was
the start of me going oh wow
this is like a real baby
it has a birth certificate
i get to take care of it i remember
wanting one so so so badly we suddenly
saw kids who were a consuming force
and they were influencing all the
purchases in the house
and by christmas 1983
demand for cabbage patch kids reaches
epidemic proportions helped in no small
degree by the news media reporting a
shortage of dolls
what is it that has left at least 10
people injured and two arrested why are
parents suddenly acting like children in
an attempt to get their children a doll
that will make them act like paris
if your kids wanted a specific one if
you didn't find it you were done like
the parents were dead to them so that's
why the fights broke out is that what
christmas is about that's i agree with
you 100
a full grown woman taking a dowel out of
a child's head
you know we would knock somebody out
during christmas time to get one because
that's what we did
when the dust settles three million
cabbage patch kids have new homes sales
continue at a steady pace until of
course kids freely express their
collective thought that they want the
next big thing the cabbage patch kid
didn't really make it out of the 80s
this is a relic um you gave this to a
kid today they probably wouldn't know
what to do with it
i'm in my 40s and i have to tell you
that just holding this one right now
it just brings back all those memories
i'm sorry i need to hook her
so we've had cute ponies mutant
creatures and cabbage patch dolls but
now something a little more challenging
simple but complex
cool but dorky and i personally have
never been able to figure it out myself
kind of like the 80s
[Music]
it was a torture device thinly disguised
as a children's toy everybody had one i
remember trying it i don't think i ever
solved it i tried to solve it for days
and days and days
it came from behind the iron curtain to
conquer the world a cube of plastic that
soon became an addictive toy and as is
so often the case our story begins with
one man with a dream
it's the late 70s
tom cramer and myself as his assistant
were at the nuremberg toy fair
his eyes lit up because he saw this
extraordinary
cube in the hands of this representative
kramer discovers the representative is a
hungarian architecture professor by the
name of erno wait for it rubik
rubik had invented the cube decades
before as a teaching aide it was
designed to solve engineering problems
and the idea being that there's a moving
piece
while something else stays stationary
and suddenly somebody said hey that's a
puzzle
[Music]
kramer is taken with both rubik and his
cube but struggles to convince backers
in the west of its potential as a toy
their first reaction was always we
cannot sell
something that you cannot solve
[Music]
tom persuaded the ideal toy company
representative to go to hungary to see
the people in the street solving the
cube that was how he finally made the
ideal toy company say yes
in 1980 the rubik's cube launches
globally and a phenomenon is born
around the world for millions of people
this rubik's cube this year has become a
maddening addiction
in its first year alone 4.5 million
cubes are snapped up kids compete in
schoolyards across america trying to
solve the brain teaser of the decade
there was always one kid that could do
this thing in five seconds at every
school i was obsessed with solving it
and i did finally solve it i got put
into advanced math courses after that
why do young kids do this better than i
asked professor ruby he said kids do it
better because they're not prejudiced to
believe that they shouldn't be able to
do it but we all know it's impossible so
we give up and smash it against the
fireplace i had absolutely no idea what
to do with it easiest way to make the
rubik's cube work was just peel off the
stickers and put them back
but for the cubers who don't need to
cheat competitions spring up all over
the world
it's been over 40 years since the cube
defected from the east and 450 million
cubes have been sold even today around
20 million cubes sell each year the
rubik's cube became this pop culture
puzzle we start seeing them in movies
start seeing them in tv shows it was
everywhere
i'm taking this cube thing with me
i don't understand it
but i will
[Music]
it's a simple cube that embodies a
simple yet elusive dream elegance
simplicity and complexity all in
something you can hold in the palm of
your hand
these are the qualities that have earned
the cube its number one rank of all 80s
toys
it's just an icon yes there are other
puzzles but the one that started it all
was the rivets keep
[Music]
[Music]
you